"Black Widow" may feel like a step backwards
for the timeline of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
but the ending to the story says a lot about
what's next for the MCU.
From Natasha's fate to the future of Yelena,
this is the ending of "Black Widow," explained.
Examining Natasha Romanoff's ending in "Black
Widow" is impossible without taking the nature
of the film as a prequel into account.
After all, we know where she's eventually
headed.
The ending of "Black Widow" just helps to
set it all up.
By the end of the film, she's got the blonde
hair we first see her sporting in "Avengers:
Infinity War," and one movie later, she sacrifices
herself to save her friends in "Avengers:
Endgame."
The movie also elaborates on Natasha's involvement
in Cap's team of secret Avengers that operated
covertly in the aftermath of "Civil War."
It turns out that she's the one responsible
for picking up the Quinjet that allows Team
Cap to continue running secret missions across
the globe for the next two years.
When "Black Widow" begins, Natasha declares
herself out of the game, but by the end of
it, she's got a new sense of purpose, making
her the driving force behind the secret Avengers
team that heads out to help the world in ways
the MCU still hasn't fully shown us.
We don't really know exactly how she went
about assembling Sam, Steve, and Wanda to
go out and help people once again, but now
we know she was an integral part of forming
the group and not just following her friends
into battle.
If Natasha's journey in "Black Widow" is about
reconnecting to her sense of purpose after
losing some of her hope during "Captain America:
Civil War," her sister Yelena's journey is
about discovering that she can actually have
a sense of purpose to call her own.
For years, Yelena has served the Red Room
and only the Red Room, and when her newfound
freedom comes, it merges with all of that
cold resolve she developed as a trained killer,
turning her into a determined force of nature.
This, of course, naturally sets her up to
be the next Black Widow in the MCU, but her
path is complicated by the arrival of Contessa
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine in her life
at some point after the events of the film,
as seen in the movie's post-credits scene
with her and Val meeting over Natasha's grave.
"Don't call me that."
"Copy."
Thanks to Valentina's influence, Yelena has
found steady work as a hired gun once again,
but whose side is she really on?
Does she even know?
Is Valentina's knack for manipulation and
temptation simply another form of control
that Yelena can feel but not see?
However it all shakes out, Yelena came out
of "Black Widow" with a new sense of freedom
and determination, and the moment she discovers
someone is trying to pull her strings, they'd
better run in the other direction.
Natasha and Yelena's "mother," Melina Vostokoff,
is one of the more fascinating members of
the "Black Widow" cast because she seems to
jump between two worlds ﻿quite comfortably,
even for a spy.
On the one hand, she's been serving the Red
Room in an advanced capacity for a long time,
working directly on the subjugation tactics
that helped her boss, Dreykov, retain an iron
grip on the Widows for years.
She seems to have no qualms at all about this,
even relishing the technology she's helped
develop, right up until she realizes what
a dramatic impact it's had on the people she
cares about.
From there, she's eager to help bring Dreykov
down, and by the end of the film, she's apparently
found a new place for herself as a kind of
caretaker to a group of orphaned Widows.
We don't know yet what Melina does after she
and Alexei Shostakov fly off with the Widows
in tow.
Perhaps she just returns to her farm, helps
out when she can, and keeps tending to her
pigs.
Perhaps she digs deeper into the worldwide
espionage community and helps Yelena to free
more Widows.
Perhaps she just enjoys a quiet retirement.
But as long as she's alive, Melina represents
an important figure in the MCU underworld,
who at any moment could shift the balance
of power with what she knows and what she
can do with that knowledge.
Of the four "family" members that served undercover
in America during the "Black Widow" prologue,
Alexei Shostakov might be the most diminished
when we meet him again in the present day.
While everyone else has had an undoubtedly
hard time, at least they weren't left to rot
away in prison.
And when we eventually catch up with him,
Alexei's glory days as the Red Guardian are
clearly long gone, but over the course of
the film, he comes to find that he might still
have some power left in his worn-down super
soldier body.
By the end of the movie, Alexei has limped
away into the sunset alongside Melina, and
where he goes from there, we don't really
know.
He could choose retirement, but something
about his personality and his love of adventure
suggests that a longing for his glory days
would eventually lure him back out into the
world.
What that means for the larger superhero community
is anybody's guess, but going forward, it's
important to remember that there's another
super soldier out there in the MCU.
With a super-powered U.S. Agent out in the
world — not to mention a new Captain America
— Red Guardian might want to make his presence
known once again.
Shortly before his death, Dreykov reveals
to Natasha that while his Red Room headquarters
might be the hub of his operation, it doesn't
begin to convey the full scope of his power.
He's got what appears to be hundreds of Widow
operatives around the world, all under his
direct control, ready to sway world governments
at a moment's notice.
"They're manipulated.
Fully conscious, but no choices."
Fortunately, before the Red Room is destroyed,
Natasha manages to copy all of Dreykov's data,
giving her the locations of all of these Widows
and, perhaps, the opportunity for Yelena and
her to free all of them in time.
The key question, though, is what each of
these women might do if and when they're freed.
How many of them actually like what they're
doing and are perhaps predisposed to more
villainous tendencies?
How many of them will simply become adrift
and lost when their purpose is taken away?
How many will want to perhaps become future
Avengers or maybe SWORD agents?
There are a lot of lingering questions -- and
a lot of potential wild cards -- in that data
file.
Perhaps no other figure in "Black Widow" better
exemplifies Dreykov's legacy of cruelty better
than his own daughter, who spends most of
the film as the masked figure known as Taskmaster.
For years, Natasha has believed that she ordered
the killing of Dreykov's daughter, part of
the "red" in her ledger that she was going
to spend her life wiping clean.
But Dreykov actually managed to save the girl
... only to then transform her into a killing
machine deployed against his most high-value
targets.
By the end of the film, Dreykov's daughter
is freed by Natasha and Yelena, but it's still
an open question whether she can ever have
anything even resembling a normal life.
Even more than the other Red Room Widows,
she exemplifies the depths of her father's
cruelty and ruthlessness.
That leaves deep psychological scars along
with all the combat skills, and she might
never fully heal.
But if she does feel like stepping back out
into the field, having Taskmaster fighting
alongside the good guys would be a sight to
see.
A key point of the "Black Widow" plot is Natasha's
realization that Dreykov -- the man she thought
she'd killed as part of her defection mission
to SHIELD -- is not only still alive but still
running the Red Room from a secret sky base.
In fact, his grip on power is tighter than
it's ever been.
Sure, by the end of the film, Natasha has
managed to truly end Dreykov once and for
all, but the character's legacy and its ripple
effects could be part of the MCU for years
to come.
Dreykov wasn't just a charismatic, powerful
leader with a firm grasp on what it took to
rule from the Red Room.
He was also the keeper of a dangerous chemical
compound that allowed him to control even
those closest to him in perpetuity, a technology
he stole from an American lab in 1995 and
perfected.
We know from the film that Dreykov wasn't
the first to experiment with chemical brainwashing,
and we also know that someone else developed
a formula to stop his mind-control tech in
its tracks.
So, what happens now?
It's unlikely that Dreykov simply died with
no loose ends left in that technological chain.
His legacy of pain and control doesn't end
with him, and we've perhaps only begun to
see the implications of it in the wider MCU.
Who knows where that mind-controlling chemical
might show up next and in what form?
The post-credits scene of "Black Widow" reveals
that Yelena has taken a job with Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine -- an influential woman
who wields a still-mysterious amount of power
in the Marvel espionage world -- and that
Val is preparing to send Yelena off to target
Clint Barton.
Val tells Yelena that Clint is responsible
for Natasha's death during "Endgame," which
is a stretch, but if there's one thing we
learned about Val from "The Falcon and the
Winter Soldier," it's that she's not afraid
to play fast and loose with the truth to get
what she wants.
This one scene creates major ties between
"Black Widow," "The Falcon and the Winter
Soldier," and the upcoming "Hawkeye" series
that will star Clint and his young protege,
Kate Bishop.
We also know that Yelena will be making an
appearance, although we're not sure if she'll
get to meet up with characters like John Walker,
aka Val's other major asset at the moment,
or the Power Broker Sharon Carter in the near
future.
What we do know, though, is that Yelena's
willingness to go deeper into Marvel's world
of espionage means that she's primed to be
every bit the Black Widow her sister was ... and
perhaps even more.
Much has been made of Natasha Romanoff's declaration
in "Avengers: Endgame" that she had nothing
until she found her Avengers "family," particularly
in light of "Black Widow" and its status as
a prequel to both "Infinity War" and "Endgame."
The film's trailers seemed to set up that
Natasha actually did have a family in some
form all along, so why would she simply discount
them in favor of her new superhero pals?
"Family Reunion,"
"You don't know everything about me.
The Avengers weren't my first family."
In the end, "Black Widow" does a very good
job explaining why Natasha felt that way and
why she phrased that much-discussed "Endgame"
sentence the way she did.
As the movie reveals, Natasha did have what
felt like a real family as a young girl, only
to have it taken away from her in devastating
fashion.
The trauma of that origin story ultimately
drove her to defect, join SHIELD, and become
an Avenger.
She found a sense of family with the Avengers,
and if she hadn't earned that through them,
she might never have been able to reconnect
with her original family the way she did.
So, by the end of the film, Natasha notes
that she actually had two families all along,
but it took finding the second one to open
her heart enough for her to rediscover the
first.
It's not a contradiction.
It's just a convoluted journey that still
allowed her to reach the same conclusion.
Becoming an Avenger made her a better person,
and the ripple effects of doing good brought
her back to something she thought she'd lost
long ago.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.